A vending machine toy capsule wall
and Charlie Sheen mask
Vsauce, Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
You know Mario Kart's
Rainbow Road?
Well, here's the rainbow walk way.
It's a 52 metre panorama located on the
roof of a building in Denmark
and visitors can walk around.
Wow.
So that's what life as a hula hoop looks like.
Well, alright. And here's what the
tallest LEGO building looks like.
Children in Brazil pieced together
500,000 LEGOs
and then a guy on a crane stacked them
over 102
feet.
The Reactable's an electronic musical
instrument with a tangible user
interface. By placing blocks on the table
and interfacing with the visual display,
a virtual modular synthesizer is operated and,
okay, just check this out.
Okay, now which one of these things is a robot?
And time's up.
Now, beer bot. Exploders guns are
kind of like a paintball gun
mixed with a water gun. They use amo
called "H2 Grow Exploders"
that can shoot up to 85 feet. These dairy
cows in China have been genetically
modified to produce human breast milk.
Sun explosion.
Hey, you kids want some wet ice cream?
This amphibious ice cream van,
the first of its kind, floats around
London and makes about as much sense as
trombone flame thrower.
This flame bone is made up from plumbing, torch
and compressed air parts and shoots a 21 foot
fireball.
Which maybe the armor sleeve can stop.
Equipped with a high-voltage stutter,
video camera and flash light.
A pull pane preps the stutter
and a button on the palm activates it.
It's encased with a hard shell and,
oh, there's Kevin Costner.
Finally, here's the Zelda theme brought to you by
the Tesla Orchestra.
I'm gonna leave you with a riddle.
"The ages of a father and son add up to 66.
"The father's age is the son's age reversed.
"How old could they be?"
There are three possible answers/
The first person to get all 3 answers
right and name the anime reference
in this video will be our genius of the week.
So good luck.
And as always,
thanks for watching.